hey youtubers it's Charlie so we learned
about a whole bunch of comic book
characters that are in spider-man
homecoming there's like a big list so
I'm just gonna do a breakdown silk is
probably the biggest person on that list
so a couple of the big characters you
already know about like your you know
about Peter Parker you know about Flash
Thompson you know about Ned Leeds here
who becomes Hobgoblin in the future but
there's a whole bunch of other comic
book characters on here it's almost like
there have a bunch of normal high school
kids that just happen to have names they
carry super comic book baggage so
they're just giving themselves a place
to go because most of the main
characters that we run into are Peters
age they're sophomores we'll follow them
the rest of the way through high school
so you can see they're winking a comic
book fans in giving themselves some
place to go if they want to do some of
these big comic book characters in the
future like if they wanted to do
Hobgoblin in the future they'll have
already spent a lot of time developing
net leads when they get there so moving
down the list we have Liz Allen who
winds up getting married to Harry Osborn
in the future they have a son called
Normie Osborn so remains to be seen
whether or not we're going to see any of
the Osborn family but they exist in the
universe so we might just see Oscorp or
we might see Easter eggs but that's kind
of her a comic book connection that we
had Betty Brant who works with Peter
Parker and Ned Leeds at the Daily Bugle
in the comics she winds up getting
married - Ned Leeds like their
relationship coincided with him being
outed as Hobgoblin you know about
zendaya Mary Jane she's listed as
Michelle here which might be Michelle
Gonzales I'm expecting bait-and-switch
but it's totally possible that she is
playing Michelle and we're all just
chasing a rumor so just keep that in the
back of your mind but it does feel like
the movie is gonna drop and then we'll
find out that she really is playing Mary
Jane and they've just been using this
Michelle name on all the call sheets as
cover for that so next big one boh keen
would bind this is a big one
shocker another big comic book villain
so it's reasonable to assume that we
will see him being shocker in a costume
sometime in the movie but miss Allen
here doesn't necessarily ring any bells
but there is a jackal miles Warren he
has a daughter that we never knew the
name of in the comics she could totally
be part of his family mr. Harrington was
actually a character who was an
administrator at Peter school who hired
him to be the science teacher also hired
Flash Thompson to be the
gym teacher so that was obviously much
later in Peters life but it sounds like
Martin Starr might be a teacher at
Peters high school principal Morita this
is actually kind of fun he's not a comic
book character but Kenneth Choi was also
in Captain America his last name he was
a howling commando his last name in that
movie was Morita so it's just an easter
egg for that the next big one Cindy this
might be Cindy moon who is silk in the
comics it does seem like the movie is
building room for other spider family
people like you'd be funny if we saw
spider-gwen but I'm not expecting that
like we'll see Gwen Stacy I'm not
expecting spider Quinn but I do like the
idea that they'll do silk eventually so
that's kind of like our backdoor to
Spider virgin anagen so that could be a
lot of fun down the road that's actually
the biggest surprise on this list the
fact that they would do so but there's
also another character Jason here Jason
miss sindell was jack-o'-lantern in the
comics but he also became a subsequent
version of Hobgoblin he picked up the
mantle of Hobgoblin after Ned Leeds so
there are two people on this list that
are Hobgoblin in the comics but like I
said most of these big comic book
characters are all sophomores in high
school so I'm not really expecting
anyone to put any tights on anytime soon
besides Peter Parker but you guys can
let me know in the comments do you think
that we're gonna see Cyndi moon silk in
this movie and do you think that
eventually she'll actually become the
silk character so hopefully they will
actually like some of these big comic
book characters that become either
villains or heroes in the future in the
comics will actually pay out because one
of my biggest complaints against the
last couple of spider-man films were
that we got Felicia Hardy but they in no
way implied that she would become black
cat eventually like this is a
billion-dollar franchise you don't
choose people's names arbitrarily like
don't give someone a really big
comic-book name if you don't intend to
pay that off eventually now obviously
you can go a number of different ways
but I feel like they're building
potential for some of these characters
to become their comic book personas
really I think the strongest chance that
we have of that is Cindy moon becoming
silk-like I'm not expecting to see venom
space knight in any of these new
spider-man movies but let me know in the
comments which of these comic book
characters do you think will actually be
wearing tights by the end of the trilogy
and I know I haven't talked about
vulture or tinkerer those are two big
comic book
characters but we already know that
Michael Keaton is playing vulture tinker
it seems like is being played by this
person who is going to help vulture make
his flight suit which i think is pretty
cool so we're only seeing a handful of
the names that are actually on this list
and it's actually just from a certain
day of filming so there's a whole bunch
of other big comic book characters that
we're gonna see in the movie the
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner David a row you
win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round of the
giveaway that starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so if there's
any bonus videos that you guys want me
to do for spider-man spiders and of the
other spider family characters like silk
just let me know in the comments while
you guys wait for my next video you can
click here to learn all about The
Avengers infinity war guardians of the
galaxy crossover and you can click here
to learn all about Mary Jane and
spider-man homecoming thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight